Hi, I’m Andre Meadows and this is Crash
Course Games.
Today we’re going to take a brief look at
the world of PC Gaming.
That’s right PC Master Race we’ve got you covered.
Because computers did start the video game
age after all.
They were the precursor of the console, hand-held systems, and all other technological gaming genres.
But just because PC Games led to all the other types of video games doesn’t mean they’re antiquated.
PC gamers prefer playing on computers because they provide a gaming landscape where players, designers, and developers intermingle.
Players can alter and modify their systems and games to their tastes, and unlike on consoles, designers and developers craft games untethered to a single machine.
And this world of PC Gaming is so diverse and imaginative that you might find games like Meatboy, 7th Guest, and RollerCoaster Tycoon all on the same computer.
And Minesweeper don’t forget Minesweeper.
PC Gaming continues to be a powerhouse and
the foundation for all modern video games.
So let’s take a look at how they got their
start and where they are going in the future.
[Theme Music]
So, pretty much as soon as computers appeared after World War II, people started making games to play on them.
But you’ve seen those early computer pictures.
They were huge.
It wasn’t until the microprocessor was developed in the 1960s and 70s, when computers morphed from room-sized behemoths to the desktop, and eventually to the handheld ones we know today.
In 1974, MITS or the Micro Instrumentation and Telemetry Systems Company introduced the Altair 8800, a build-it-yourself computer kit.
It didn’t have a keyboard or screen, but it did give feedback through a row of lights that flashed back at people.
This is considered the first commercially
successful PC.
But home computers didn’t grab the public’s
gaming imagination at first.
It was the advent of arcade machines that
did it.
Games like Pong, Gun Fight, and Lunar Lander filled arcades all over the world due to their ease of play and availability.
This in turn led to home consoles like the Odyssey, Atari, and ColecoVision, which we talked about earlier in the series.
At the same time, PCs were evolving at an
amazing rate.
Computer gaming continued to grow, and by the late 1970’s video games began to split into two different, though intrinsically linked lines.
On one side you had the dedicated gaming consoles that eventually lead to Nintendo, Sega, Xbox, and Playstation.
On the other side, we saw PC gaming nestle
deep into the world of computers.
Interesting enough, the rise of PC Gaming began in the US just before the Great Video Game Crash of 1983.
The Crash caused the public to lose faith
in home consoles.
And PCs were there with open arms to quickly
welcome this new audience.
How did PCs survive?
Well, after the crash they were clever to advertise themselves as machines that could do more than simply play games.
They sold the public on the PC's ability to
multi-task.
Yes, you could play games, but you could also manage taxes, study geography, and do homework too.
PC sales began to grow, and games came along
with them.
The classic Commodore 64 is a great example
of the PC's success at this time.
It came out in 1982 and was founded by computer
businessman Jack Tramiel.
During its 12 year lifespan, over 17 million units were sold and a staggering 10,000 commercial programs were made.
Technologically-speaking, the Commodore 64
was a huge step forward.
It ran on a MOS 6510 microprocessor that gave
it 64 kilobytes of RAM. Wow.
The display could create 16 colors, 40 columns,
and 25 lines of text with a 320 x 200 resolution.
That might all sound quaint today but back
then that was cutting edge.
What kept people coming back was the ever-increasing
games and program library.
You could find a program on just about anything for the C64, there were 10 thousand of them remember?
But if you couldn’t, and had the skills,
you could probably program it yourself.
And that sense of openness and opportunity for experimentation can still be found in many PC gamers today.
In the United Kingdom, another early computer would also heavily influence the industry - the ZX Spectrum.
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble.
Released by Sinclair Research Ltd in 1982, the ZX Spectrum, with its efficient design, was the brainchild of the company’s founder Sir Clive Sinclair.
He was literally a genius -- the guy designed a compact submarine at the age of 14 -- and a lover for all things computer.
One of Sinclair’s first creations was the
ZX80.
It had a great price point but was underpowered,
even for the day.
It barely had 900 bytes of RAM.
In today’s terms that’s about six tweets.
Thankfully Sinclair learned from his mistakes.
The ZX Spectrum addressed a lot of the early issues, and would go on to become a British gaming institution.
While it still had a few shortcomings and was received poorly everywhere else in the world,
the ZX Spectrum had more influence over gaming in the U.K. than the original NES.
There were six magazines and well over 24,000
games devoted to the Spectrum.
It was so successful that Sinclair was knighted
by Queen Elizabeth II.
The system became a point of national pride and even won out against more technologically sound PCs like the Commodore 64.
The Spectrum inspired generations of game creators such as Chris Davis, the one man team of Mouldy Toof Studios and developer of The Escapists.
Davis cited the Spectrum as his inspiration,
saying that,
“My interest in making games started back
as a kid with the ZX Spectrum.
While all of my friends were moving into the 16-bit era, the Spectrum was my first proper dose of video gaming.”
Thanks Thought Bubble!
So, by the start of the 1990’s, PC Gaming was moving towards a golden age, ushering in a number of unique gaming experiences that could only be found on a PC.
Let’s start with real-time strategy or RTS.
This genre of PC game play focuses on securing locations and destroying your opponent’s assets through resource gathering, base building, technological development, and indirect control of units.
Dune II: the Building of a Dynasty was one of the first games to establish RTS as we know it today.
The game was released in 1992 and included key elements of RTS such as a world map to choose the next mission,
different factions, mobile and base unit construction, and funding through resource gathering.
But what really made RTS and Dune II special was the use of the mouse and keyboard to move units within the game.
According to its co-designer and lead programmer,
Joe Bostic,
"This greatly facilitated precise player control, which enabled the player to give orders to individual units.
The mouse, and the direct control it allowed,
was critical in making the RTS genre possible.”
This game has gone on to inspire other monumental
games such as Starcraft and Warcraft.
First person shooters also flourished in the
PC space.
Using 3D graphics, these games allowed players much greater freedom of movement, compared to many other games of the time.
Wolfenstein 3D is the game that really made
this genre popular.
Released in 1992 on MS-DOS, interestingly as shareware, Wolfenstein helped establish the basic mechanics of this genre and still heavily influences FPS games today.
Not to mention serving as the template for Doom.
And we can’t talk about PC games without
mentioning simulators.
Simulators attempt to simulate real life activities like flight or surgery by allowing for freely controlled characters and environments.
Now it can be argued that some simulators aren’t actually games as many are used for on-the-job training or education vs leisure play.
But one of the most popular simulators, that
is definitely a game, is SimCity.
Released in 1989 (okay, not quite the 90s, but close enough) SimCity simulated various aspects of city management.
The game also features one of the defining aspects of simulation - that there is no clearly defined goal for the player to achieve.
And game publishers weren’t too receptive to the idea, thinking that the game would sell poorly.
But SimCity was a runaway success selling
an estimated 1 million copies by 1992.
I even owned a copy of SimCity, but I owned it on Super Nintendo don’t judge me it had Bowser in it.
Now, we know that puzzles aren’t technically considered games, but throw puzzle solving into a narrative and you’ve got yourself an adventure.
The adventure genre is typically designed for a single player who acts as the protagonist of the story, solving puzzles to progress through the game.
Now, the initial adventure games were text-based, where the computer would translate the input into commands for the game.
As PCs became more powerful, graphics were
added to create an illustrated narrative.
Take Myst for example.
Originally released in 1993, players walked around an oddly quiet and mysterious island attempting to solve various puzzles and riddles.
This game was unusual for the time because it provided little character backstory, there was no physical violence, and no goals laid out for the player.
I'm sensing a trend here with PC games.
But Myst was a huge success and helped pave a new avenue in the puzzle gaming genre, inspiring games like 7th Guest, 11th Hour, and even its own sequel.
Also, we can thank Myst for helping drive
the adoption of the CD-ROM.
You’re welcome Playstation and other future
gaming consoles.
With the 90s, we also see the rise of LAN
parties or Local Area Network parties.
These were gatherings where people could connect
their computers to play multi-player games.
In 2013, Sweden saw the biggest LAN party to date with over 17,000 devices connected during the DreamHack festival.
Today, we see unprecedented access to PC games.
Internet portal sites are popping up, like NewGrounds and Kongregate, delivering gaming to millions.
Sites like Neopets have become commonplace,
allowing anyone to log in and play from anywhere.
PC gaming has also led to the rise of gaming
platforms like Steam by Valve.
Steam is an online service that distributes games and other media created by developers to its shared subscriber base.
Officially released in 2003, Valve has continued to thrive for years, and may be ushering in the next golden age of PC gaming.
There are over 125 million active Steam users worldwide, and the system has over 4500 games and 400 million items created by users.
Valve even has its own VR unit but we’ll
get into that in the next episode.
And PC Gaming really sets itself apart because both players and creators can take part in the creation process.
Take mods, for example, where people alter a game mechanic to their own, often bizarre, liking.
The practice of modding has led to all kinds of wonderfully bizarre, funny, and challenging new games like Macho Man Randy Savage in Skyrim.
Or Marty McFly and his time-traveling Delorean on the streets of San Andreas in Grand Theft Auto.
This could also lead to a problem like cheating
but I digress.
Not going to get into that.
That’s your conscience.
It’s clear that PC gaming is thriving, and continues to inform many games on a variety of platforms.
Some game genres truly are best when played on a PC, and many great games can only be played on this platform.
PC gaming has inspired originality in game
development like no other platform.
It’s come a long way since Minesweeper.
Which can someone really tell me the rules
of Minesweeper I still don’t get it.
Thanks for watching and we’ll see you next
time!
Crash Course Games is filmed in the Chad and
Stacey Emigholz Studio in Indianapolis, Indiana,
and it's made with the help of all these nice
people.
If you'd like to keep Crash Course free for everyone forever, you can support the series at Patreon, a crowdfunding platform that allows you to support the content you love.
Speaking of Patreon, we'd like to thank all
our patrons in general, and we'd like to specifically
thank our High Chancellor of Knowledge, Morgan
Lizop, and our Vice Principal, Michael Hunt.
Thank you for your support.